et il faut pas mentir dans le tchat
vous êtes impatients et vous avez les
yeux complètement ébahi devant ce
magnifique spectacle qui nous attend le
match que tout le monde attend ça fait
depuis janvier un conte en parle de
cette demi finale
on l'attend on l'attend et les états
unis qui aligne deux super gros joueurs
aux deux premiers échiquiers jeffrey
xiang et
et dariusz filière c'est bien sûr la
grosse équipe des états unis un qui a
été sortie on ne fait pas jouer les plus
faibles ici attention certains joueurs
pourraient se sentir visés alors
question d'une carreaux cannes
ça fait plaisir
et oui il y a des joueurs absents mais
ils sont probablement absent par leur
manque de niveau
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez dans
le tchad ces gens sont peut-être pas
encore arrivé mais c'est vrai qu'on se
pose on se pose la question sur la non
titularisation de certains
c'est hyper théorique ça comme variante
salut finistère taxer et alliés se
passer des services
d'un streamer bien connu dans le milieu
sûrement probablement moins fort que chu
young et que 18 h oui hein ça se
présente un petit peu quand même
ça se présente quand même un petit peu
salut merlin bis mayor qui allez vous
êtes pour qui voyager un peu des
messages qu'ils partent
attendez j'écris pour la prod cette
ligne
un truc c'est pour la prod chez sig
donc tant des
j'ai qu'un petit truc
un petit truc
donc ça a joué ces petites car aucun
vous connais pas on n'est pas très
nombreux pour le moment sur ce live
y'a pas grand monde en vrai
mais on va tenter un truc très
technologique après
nantes qui réfléchit un c'est la théorie
ça c'est une variante que j'ai déjà vu
mazeau jouer visuellement ça a l'air
très bien pour les blancs mais bon
cavalier peut se faire enfermer et ça
peut mal tourner
un duel sautant faire un tt ah mais
c'est prévu en fait je vais tenter
d'envoyer deux stream en même temps sur
le même ordre avec moi qui stream ça est
maso de l'autre côté
qui stream le title on va tenter ça
c'est un peu dur à faire mais il ya une
chance
il ya un monde où ça marche
mais à c'est loin d'être sûr parce que
c'est pas évident mais mais ça se tente
il est fou prend bien en fait pour
éviter que les pions avance
il apprend pas la tour pour le moment de
façon il apprend un peu quand il veut en
réalité
un peu le tourner des échiquiers aoyama
italie j'adorerais y schalit
entre cervantes lande d'airou talia
france éliminée ouais il ya plus de
france
c'est bon il y avait un peu des gens
tout à l'heure qui seront venus ce matin
là il ya juste personnes je crois que
c'est le pire horaires en plus 17h30
pour nous
c'est le premier le deuxième rang des
premiers
une musique personnelle je crois qu'il y
avait déjà des problèmes de notices
aussi globalement je vous parle non mais
non mais non oui en fait j'ai arrêté de
commenter de toute façon on frappe à la
fin du norway on avait fait un vote la
dernière fois et ça intéresse personne
en fait ça intéresse son père
donc vu que ça intéresse personne on va
on va pas le faire
tout bêtement
je pense que c'est la bonne solution non
je sais pas ce que vous vous en pensez
mais je pense c'est la bonne solution
plus personne ne voulait rugueux regardé
c'était long et a de toute façon
aujourd'hui j'ai ça demain j'ai ça aussi
et en vrai dans tous les cas c'était
prévu ne pas le faire
soir l'uci
et le kef par contre aux vidéos avec
mathieu son top away franchement il ya
eu l'énorme boulot en derrière
j'espère que ça vous plaît mais nous
nous on bosse comme des malades pour
vous faire des belles vidéos
le sol africain avec le nord-ouest et
les vidéos d'analystes de toute façon je
suis d'accord avec vous
c'est un x 3 ou 7
bien kiffé le en 1963 il était plus un
port intéressant le 960
on va laisser jouer de façon un peu vu
ce matin le match en vrai ça devient
intéressant à la fin là jusqu'à la fin
il n'y a pas vraiment d'intérêt quoi
dans le match on soit parce qu'on peut
pas vraiment avoir la globalité du match
a trop de trucs qui se passe et ce qui
est marrant c'est quand sa clique à la
fin pas marrant
façon de parler
vidéo sur apporte tout même si la partie
m'a fait mal à tétouan était complexe
mais du coup il faut il faut attendre la
fin
je pense que l'inde va les déchirer mais
bon
déjà honnêtement il manque tous les
meilleurs joueurs américains en fait
donc c'est vrai que ça pose problème
parce que si tanaka caruana devant c'est
pas la même que sugar et krishna 1
c'est pas la même
le tight note le moment qui sauf si vous
avez des questions n'hésitez pas c'est
le moment un peu de discuter de schille
ya pas grand monde sur le tchat
april à tournon
il n'a pas perte de temps de
développement il devait il aurait
peut-être dû l'apprendre
voulait pas réactiver la dame perdre du
temps en fait je veux récupérer le cac
va les envoyer les puntos l'os benauge
hier elle prévue cette année un élan
avec le co vip complex un
tape oscillations avec vlad ouais
c'était sympa hier
quelques parties savaient plus
impressionnant ma vie aucune idée
peut-être un djoko nadal
est parti chez koei amis il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à faire mais
je mangeais déjà expliqué en fait il ya
beaucoup de choses qui vont pas genre
énormément c'est pour ça qu'il ya
personne qui regarde et de moins en
moins tu vois si on regarde là
surtout que les chiffres de chess comme
ils sont un peu biaisé mais à que 4800
spectateurs donc en organique il doit y
avoir 700 800 spectateurs en anglais
pour un match des états unis matin ils
étaient 400 pour pour le match en russe
à
l'aggravement personnes
pourquoi pas un hymne un hymne anglais
d'ado attardé ce que je suis un ado
attardé en fait versini doit être
tellement intelligents qui doivent
battre très facilement aux échecs toi va
être vraiment très fort
ouais non il ya
ces cas tile norwich est encore plus
qu'atteint afin ouais ça date à peu près
pareil cas tu as
ça pourrait être une des vidéos à
l'occasion des meilleurs moments des
parties présentées hier soir par vlad ça
allait un peu vite pour moi ouais ouais
ça peut être sympa en fait ces vidéos
qu'on voulait tourner ensemble avec
vannes l'on n'avait pas eu le temps
quand il était vu la dernière fois
sympa avec vague par contre j'ai rien
compris aux coups magiques vous avez
montré trop complexe pour moi en fait
faut voir un truc c'est que tous les
coûts qui vont réellement être beau pour
des professionnels vous n'allez pas vous
n'allez pas les comprendre en fait quand
tu montes des beaucoup aux amateurs sont
souvent des sacrifices de dames ou quoi
qui pour nous sont hyper basique et pas
très intéressant
et les coups qu'on va vraiment aimé il
va être trop complexe
leur a présenté avec vlad hier c'était
juste incroyable bas il est sur ma
chaîne youtube à se secouer incroyable
de terrorisme at
the links tu décides les équipes je mets
sonaca murat
caruana en remplaçant
très clairement
là le fou a peut-être revenir en a3
coutal oui mais sa reprise trois façons
en fait ces trucs qui sont beaux
mais mais en fait la stratégie et les
idées à long terme pour nous c'est plus
beau quoi
ce qu'on va être souvent les tactiques
nous on peut les trouver
alors qu'à certains qu'ouvrière que
j'aurais pas trouvé
donc il ya des coups qui vous
impressionne parce que vous n'y aurais
jamais pensé mais le truc c'est que nous
on y pense aussi
il veut faire sur foix iii je crois
qu'il faut à 3 et le mail mot veille
semoule or voilà
ça nous arrange pas moins ses coûts trop
complexe messieurs ne comprend pas tout
je prends beaucoup de plaisir à voir les
analyses c'est comme la poésie et
chicken bah ouais c'est un peu c'est un
peu comme une oeuvre d'art compte
explique en fait
en fait j'ai bossé dans une galerie
d'art pendant quelques mois et il se
trouve que quand des spécialistes
expliquent les plus beaux tableaux en
fait ce qui est beau c'est pas forcément
ce que toi tu penses c'est beau de base
pas besoin d'une cette petite éducation
pour comprendre le bo en fait
en tout cas dans l'art comme ça ça c'est
intéressant plus tu t'intéresses au
sujet puis à des choses que tu aurais
trouvé lambda qui trouve bel et bien
c'est exactement la même chose avec les
échecs en fait plus tu es fort plus il
ya des choses qui sont vraiment belles
que tant capacité de comprendre
ouais
je suis la formule non pas du tout
écoute je la suis pas du tout
normalement mais j'ai dû porter la
poisse parce que hier j'ai allumé
j'allume trois grands prix par an
pendant dix minutes
et un jv le grand prix sur et trois
minutes après il y avait le
l'accrochage vers stappen hamilton donc
du coup j'ai regardé la course qui est
assez sympa ça faisait longtemps que
j'avais pas regardé parce qu'ils avaient
jamais de suspense quand je regardais et
là hier c'était assez cool
jeudi dernier sur john terry le niveau
de haine contre le rouscoff aymen
voir us aux états-unis complexe 1
je pense qu'il faut pratiquer pour
comprendre aussi genre un peintre
amateur comprendra mieux les
chefs-d'oeuvre de la peinture je pensais
bon un nom
bien enfin pas bien
égalité matérielle mais il ya du jeu
pour les noirs
hier la maison vraiment des plots les
américains c'est pas l'équipe des états
unis c'est l'équipe des plots
j'ai pas pu voir la toute la finale il
soulevé mais j'ai pu lire et j'ai revu
des extraits et une grosse présentation
en fait les indiens ils sont tellement
plus fort
et
ça c'est plutôt bien pour les blancs
je crois qu'un des vraiment plus fort
parce que hollande est censé être plus
fort que
pyong harry krishna est plus fort que ce
biais rch koné roux est plus forte que
crunch mialhe sarine guang au lion d'or
c'est 50 50
arica est plus forte que
ça t'inspire eva joly est plus forte que
cervantès donc en réalité
votre passion taschen parce que ça c'est
pas un événement que je commande sur ma
chaîne je commence pour de chasse comme
j'ai même pas commenté l'équipe de
france sur ma chaîne avant
pour dire le level d'implication du
streamer français donc j'aurai pas
streamé à la phase finale de cette
compet sur ma chaîne
pas assez intéressant
pour ma chaîne passe intéressant
terrible
ça serait me soit le tt je vais tenter
un truc j'ai tenté d'envoyer deux stream
de mon ordi en coupant le micro sur mon
vrai live pour avoir maso de l'autre
côté pouvoir avoir le tt quoi
à propos d'un indien ça a été arbitré
l'aréna par équipes alors tout pas
intéressant comme question apparemment
il ya eu trop de problèmes donc il va
soit y avoir un arbitrage massif soit
une annulation de la compétition c'est
normal puisque sinon on aurait gagné
avec un arbitrage plus ou moins normal
mais là il va peut-être falloir annulé
le truc
reichs faut une fois qu'on gagne un truc
chose
en fait je pense qu'ils veulent pas
changer de vainqueur
en vrai je vais demander
donc je ne sais pas mais apparemment ça
pourrait être fou l'annuler en fait
ce qui serait dommage
je préfère de sera temps je vais essayer
en fait je vais tenter ça le truc un peu
marrant de la journée c'est pour ça que
vous voyez si heureux en fait je suis
sûr que tu commence aujourd'hui en fait
tu peux heureux du castelat maintenant
mais je suis heureux de tenter deux
castes sur le même mardi le trouve ça
extraordinaire
parce qu'en fait sur deux ordis ce
serait facile mais faire deux régies sur
le même ordre d'idée jamais fait
du coup je suis très savoir sir leur
diva tenir et tout
mais si dray
si vous voyez
tout sourire c'est cette idée me
m'excite au plus haut point
il faut que tu utilises obs et une autre
rapidement tu peux ouvrir deux fois obs
il se moule rtx 3090 carrie
et je ne parle pas de maux de dents
tu n'as pas de faire des choses comme à
ben non moi je fais le casse le casque
je dois faire c'est juste maso qui sera
qui fera le title c'est un événement de
chaises comme aussi donc non qui vont pu
faire un fait au pied qu'est ce qui va
se passer
a demandé de chasse comme de déplacer le
title pour qu'on puisse se jouer quoi
ils m'ont dit non pas grave on va quand
même se débrouiller un nom mais en plus
c'est pour castanet ventures comme n'y
aura pas de problème puis ce sera pas
moi qui serai avec maso sur le kst
masozera salle je vais juste lancé la
régie c'est tout
en 2008 hachana je pense pas
man ils ont tout refait avec l'arena etc
mais c'est pas sûr qu'on finisse dans
les premiers à mon avis on va très mal
finir
rassure toi qui sera soleil ton tournoi
c'est ça après ça peut finir tôt s'il ya
deux sets zéro il n'y aura pas de tie
break
en train de demander pour le tournoi
comme vous me demandiez pour avoir une
réponse
peur comme
ça devrait gagner pour l'inde
bonjour les positions ça doit gagner
parce qu'ils sont plus forts en fait
même s'ils sont un peu des positions de
merde ils sont vraiment plus fort
or début de match mais ils sont plus
forts
car il y va c'est quattro
valeur du f4 haut
je tourne
tout pour me faire une idée
salut ben raween
bons joueurs d'ailleurs ben ramino d'api
et a
fait des beaux matches à castres
un joueur très sous côté je trouve
400 km h ça fait asseoir et après on a
bien expliqué
avec mathieu que ça pas très bien joué 1
la tournée se passe pas grand-chose
grand chose
ça va être dur pour arica vient se
brancher pas quelqu'un qui l'a fait dans
la rue
je m'en tiens pas de toi ce soir j'ai
encore à piketon répertoire t'as fait
quoi la première barre à mine
j'aime bien blanc ici quand même hein
il va tenter de de pousser les pions
donc à
un pur
pour cervantès à la claque et du matos
et à la plus trop d'attac
j'ai gagné en écrasant
mon adversaire
c'est bien que la finale n'ait pas été
beau et par fille rouge à ce genre de
finale sont tout le temps joué à la
perfection et se sont pas joués sont pas
joué du tout là on a une illustration de
ce qu'il faut pas faire wes et c'est
pour ça que je dis que c'était hyper
pédagogique pourquoi est ce qu'il aurait
fallu faire c'est d'autant plus cool
qu'en général on n'a jamais de temps
final si on connaît pas les plans ouais
mais ça qui est bien c'est que ali reza
a très mal joué en réalité un plat
disaient qu'ils pensaient que ces
niveaux 25 50 mais quand on voit la
vidéo moi qui suis 2003 me manque et je
veux vraiment beaucoup mieux les finales
que mon que mon lots le suggère mais eux
et tu vas même si on pense que joua les
finales à 2005 2005 50 en fait la
variante qu'il fallait jouer d'après
alors dit j'aurais joué tempo sans
réfléchir et firent où déjà il a claqué
genre 45 minutes pour mal jouer donc
c'est qu'il a quand même une énorme
lacune c'est pas possible en fait de
prendre autant de temps et de moins bien
joué que mon premier réflexe
skype 6 h 6 g 5 en fait j'aurais fait en
blitz ou même en bullet fait c'est tu
fais avec les mains quoi
mais après baladi pense qu'il va régler
le problème j'ai discuté avec lui au
téléphone après il m'a dit vas bosser à
fond avec
avec qui bossent d'ailleurs
et à
et du cou a dit hé ouais bah il va le
faire bosser huit heures par jour lui
met des positions mais en réalité pour
pour ce truc là
je dirais de manière un peu vulgaire
mais mais mais c'est blad qui me le
disait quand je bossais blague il
m'avait dit en fait les finales tu peux
les apprendre qu avec la douleur de tes
propres poil de cul expression de vlad
et
est du coup en vrai
il ya que le jour où tu commence
vraiment aller travailler comme commun
ou effectuent tessa est vraiment de
comprendre le pourquoi du comment es tu
sais que tu progresses vraiment temps
que tu fais pas ce boulot tout seul j'y
crois pas en fait il ya que toi qui peux
aider pour certaines choses
ct obligé de souffrir quoi pour
pour être capable de bien de bien les
jouer
vraiment c'est changer comme cet avion
dépend des vrais faut vraiment faire le
boulot soit même si non tu y arrives pas
en fait
petit stage en servi en vrai en tri même
firoud ça lui ferait du bien tu vas
là-bas tu t'enfermes avec des mecs tu
bosses quoi
en vrai il ya que comme ça si tu y fais
un châssis tapas talent naturel pour les
finales en particulier y a que comme ça
mais pour fuir ou de chasser une telle
lacune
ce thème il va gagner je pense
à juste du matériel en plus
à intéressant mais harry krishna il a
trouvé du contre je anon les américains
en fait au lieu d'avoir rica ou et
et
esso qui mettrait deux sur deux ans et
demi sur deux à toutes les parties en
fait ils se font ils sont marchés dessus
ça change tout un
mais du coup l'un d'eux l'a maintenant
ils ont vraiment lead partout
le garçon de 18 ans incomparable actuel
en deux styles complètement différents
mais en fait la différence c'est qu'à la
scène quand il arrivait son point faible
c'était le répertoire d'ouvertures et
avait l'impression qu'il allait régler
en tout simplement en ayant des seconds
ans et en améliorant le truc c'est que
fit rules à son défaut fin les deux ils
ont un défaut si les différences et les
finales mais les finales témoins sûr de
pouvoir le régler
et maintenant que carlos est l'un des
meilleurs répertoire d'ouvertures un
truc c'est le répertoire d'ouvertures
c'est assez que payer des seconds ans ça
suffit en fait les finales ça peut être
une lacune que tu rec jamais si la règle
jamais ça va être dur
par contre si la règle il va être
instante top 5 mondial
c'est mon heure l'étudiante et à tulle
haha mais nul aucun recul en fait
enfin c'est rédhibitoire pour n'importe
qui mais amélie serait pas arrivé aussi
aussi les terribles en calcul c'est pas
possible trop important le calcul pour
arriver aussi loin
mais bon nul en finale c'est un vrai
problème parce qu'en réalité avant il
est monté parce que personne ne
connaissait vraiment son point faible
enfin les gens cherchent et son gros
point faible maintenant qu'ils ont
trouvé en fait il se fait martyriser
quoi
ça ça doit être cool pour les noirs
quel ça peut tourner encore un
sur le site all things pianiste de
bouquins sur les finales way
g4g et trois ou quatre bouquins que je
recommande qui sont fantastiques en fait
faut tous les faire
un du tarif pas que la caa 5 ça le
problème
le roi moi je serais parti comme ça avec
le roi mais bon
elle va venir la
veillée mauroy c63 bessette peut faire
froid f6 uns préfèrent wife 6-3 et 6-3
5-3 bessette
mayroy bessette y avait pas y aveyron
apprend la
cave quand tu joues contre un drop bien
plus expérimentés ont c'est de jouer
agressif ou 2to blindé a parfois
attaquer pas tout à parti mais il faut
pas jouer petit bras sinon ça va être
facile pour lui
si tu ne mets pas sous pression en fait
il va avoir une partie facile donc il
faut que normal et si tu peux un peu
over presse over presse un peu quoi
ils sont peut-être compte retourner les
indiens
a bien joué et on prend 5 et prend 1,5
dame échecs dames échecs dames prend
weichs ali qui va gagner
squale aux demi finales c'est la russie
qui a éliminé la chine
il va vouloir un nom de roitg
4,3 g 5 peut-être
qu'onéreux crunch ça fait nul
si ça va faire nul normalement
ici c'est moins sûr
ici c'est beaucoup moins sûr
il faut qui vient en b 6
on va voir ça devrait gagner pour l'un
dans ce premier set
aïcha lis ça gagne
dans le cas de dame ces trois dames h un
match très joli voilà pour mettre le
pion ces deux et il n'y a pas un échec
ça ça gagne ça fait un point ça ça peut
gagner pour les états unis ça peut faire
un nid à elle ça va faire ça va laisser
1 1 il y aura pas de victoire
là
ça peut gagner pour harry krishna et
faire 2 1 et un andré normalement
les chaudes son côté indien
et prend les quatre vous prend des
quatre enfants dès 4 ans à 4 et la
finale doit gagner tranquille en fait
va faire tour d2 autour des 1 il va y
avoir tout raciste qui avait prend aussi
soin papy fait de la résistance
résistance ça
il va voir tout reprend et qu'avait lieu
4 et il va ramener le roi
est chopé le pion
donc ça peut se jouer sur celle-là a
baissé aussi l'indien qui va gagner a
laissé la différence 1 tu mets à
ouais ça fait toute la différence ne pas
mettre ses meilleurs joueurs
et ces trois doigts je pointe of the
spinoff
ac3 fou prend 1,6 mais tour à
eastbourne auch faut prendre assisteurs
points à 6 la tour prend b2
j'en prends ont pensé huit matches mais
fou prend assistera le spin off le
speech et auch
dois-je punto ce qu'ils vont gagner
et oui oui on juste faire 2-0 côté
américain ça fait 2-0 côté indien quand
il manquait deux joueurs
c'est complexe
en fait ici un nom des
six les deux gagnants fête se termina
d'eau instantané
m lecavalier a eu trois attaques et le
pion maintenant à faire 3-2 ces deux
rois des deux
ça à faire deux pions plus c'est fini
pour quoi un caennais jouent pas la cote
américain parce que la compétition n'est
pas intéressante en fait
donc les meilleurs joueurs ne jouent pas
maxime n'a pas joué en équipe de france
firoud déjà non plus et
ballack et étrangers quatre cavaliers
six cavaliers 17 le grand classique
la joue en france varie manquer les
meilleures fins il manque les meilleurs
de partout quoi
et ça s'est fini donc ça finit à voir là
cette partie va finir ce premier set
avoir une petite vingtaine de minutes de
pause à présent
et or c'est à la fin pour bien enfoncer
et j'estime quoi
je pars convaincu gesing groupe perso
mais bon
ça fait façon ces dames de plus
hier c'était pas indispensable
hélas
à temps que cela se termine dans la
victoire des morts avec la dame de plus
donnera
français 7 1
qui passe et voilà c'est terminé ce
premier mini match n'aura pas eu de
suspense
et surtout qu'à arica gagne aussi
ah ouais il manque
100 ouest les sauts les usa sont
vraiment dominés 1
c'est vrai qu'il manque il manque
vraiment rester dans cette équipe votre
façon le match est déjà terminée le
premier mini match est déjà terminée les
indiens ont déjà les trois points
et ça va même faire 4-4 puntos
un dollar
saab en on arrivait à gagner reste plus
qu'une partie
civile a joué jusqu'au bout mais en tout
cas les indiens bien au-dessus
beau match en tout cas un magnifique
pour le moment un spectacle vraiment au
rendez vous
le spectacle est vraiment au rendez-vous
en des parties de grande qualité
des joueurs exceptionnels
et partie absolument incroyable
c'est vraiment des demi finales très
qualitative
laquelle on insiste
abba plus petit parrain pour un tel
spectacle
mesdames deco permet pas aux états unis
gagne moi c'est déjà terminé 1
tle à 19 heures
je tape statut bah oui mais bon là il
faut envoyer de la petite pub est un
timide depuis par heure important
je te faut en profiter pour expliquer la
différence recalculé tactique un calcul
c'est visualiser loin dans le temps donc
calculer
et les tactiques c'est reconnaître les
schémas tactiques c'est deux choses
complètement différentes 1
je vais même pas qu'il y avait les
olympiades appris ce matin en cliquant
sur la vidéo
ouais après y'a pas grand monde qui le
sait en fait c'est ça qui est beau
car c'est la réfection du pont depuis
longtemps et vous voulez qu'on aille
voir un peu le norway en fait en vrai
sera plus intéressant on peut aller
jeter un oeil un
djadja
n'y a pas moyen de jah jah
ok
paris
paris aucun ses positions complexes 1
pour le moment ils rapportent
c'est hyper chaud
à la c pose donc on peut aller voir un
peu le norway en sait un peu sympa on
n'est pas obligé de rester à
bloquer sur un duel ce à quoi
on va remettre qu'à une petite pub de
trois minutes histoire de bien envoyé en
fait je les envoie deux fois d'affilée
au moins vous en prenez bien
vous êtes pub aide
- vous faites bien pub est quoi je vais
essayer d'ouvrir un autre obs pour voir
si ça passe
[Musique]
je suis toujours live ici
sa daube et espace toujours
ouais
ça peut faire bugger en fait mince
au pire je relancerai
on est pendant la pause on rate rien
au pire on rate rien
beugin
donc le coup le bon coup stratégique si
le coût qui ne donne pas l'avantagé
immédiat mais qui traîne dans une
position qui a calculé à fort potentiel
tactique favorable
en fait c'est possible mais je sais pas
j'ai réfléchi à ça comme ça si
on devrait leur dit qu'ils carrisi 1
ah oui mais c'est pas moi qui décide
pour les pubs 1
s'est passé pas ma chaîne en fait ça ne
m'appartient pas mais on me dit que six
minutes de plus par heure je m'estime
unis depuis par un en vrai
un vrai c'est pas de mon ressort 1
pas de mon ressort
quand soit je peux pas grand chose en
fait ça on va revoir cette particule
début
je passe juste derrière ça va
ça marche pas en vente
j'arrivais un pied lui avait
un pad petite inconnue est vrai
qu'avec ta chaîne star ministre elle
était trop mignonne harbaoui
micha carrie un
prénom ça peut fonctionner les deux live
en même temps en fait
vu son rap à la cam de mazo mettre la
cam sera complexe mais les deux stream
en même temps peuvent fonctionner
très certainement je peux réussir
ce qui est magnifique
j'en vis ya pas trop long trop te
remercie de telestream sur ta chaîne à
toi c'est vraiment intéressant
enrichissant divertissant dans une
ambiance conviviale ça motive à
progresser alors c'est cool
je pense qu'on peut envoyer les deux
live en vrai je pourrais quasiment voyez
la cam de maso mais
ça va être un poil chauffard x à faire
un réglage supplémentaire
et pour 15 minutes ça m'embête un peu
deux instances de baisse en même temps
et je suis en train de faire ça en
gérant les micros et tous pour avoir les
bons micro
et les bons sont partout quoi
bien beaucoup dans la rue ouais souvent
vrai
band of the stranger de chêne tweet bah
c'est pas le même contenu en fait un
mois je vais pas stream sur deux chaînes
je vois pas quel monde sebban des fins
en fait j'ai juste faire la régie de la
deuxième mais je vais stream autre chose
sur ma chaîne
je repars langue allemande sebban des
fêtes
je vois pas pourquoi ça serait pas
possible
je vais juste lancé un autre crime et je
serai pas dessus
pas d'ailleurs on verra
en vrai peut-être joué juste récupérer
maso
et on aura juste maso ici qui expliquera
le début de son title
c'est madame fini qu'en 6e qui assurent
les deux live est exactement la même
chose non là ce sera complète sera deux
choses différentes
ouais je peux au courant c'est une règle
comme ça mais enfin elle me paraît très
juste absolument illogique parce qu'en
fait c'est juste envoie deux flux du
même ordre 10 mai mais ces deux fut
différent je vois pas pourquoi ça
poserait problème
ce que tu penses essence et qu ils font
passer un état pour josé échec
ça me paraît juste normal mais bon
les joueurs savent et risquent ils
feraient un tournoi à y contribuer en
resto tu sais les risques que tu prends
on enlève enfin c'est quoi cette
question en fait ça c'est la question
paraît stupide en fait
après être pour ou contre le pass annie
terre c'est une autre question mais vu
qui a le pass sanitaires pour faire tout
un tas de choses pour c'est normal qu'il
y soit pour jouer aux échecs
jamais vu un argumentaire aussi naze en
fait
peut-être qu'il ya des arguments
intéressants à pour ça mais là
l'argumentaire
même pour aller jouer au tennis j'ai
besoin du pass sanitaires
c'est terrible
bhl
terribles images s'il recommence pas
direct en fait ils font perdre du temps
là
bon on va attendre un frein à faire
d'autre
que d'attendre
sauf qu'ils n'acceptent pas le psr nan
mais ils sont obligés d'accepter le pcr
alors istac a de quoi tu parles
pcr ça donne un cette fin parce
sanitaires
m
on a attends à l'égard de façon là c'est
la pause pourrait presque comme un twin
pub 1
message sur twitter
sur ta chaine bas je sais pas en fait si
je tente le double live et de tout
casser de foi de tout casser
ou si on attend tranquillement et on
rate la première ronde d'avoir la
deuxième ronde de maso
ray c'est long c'est vraiment non
être patient plutôt que tout cas c'est
vrai
je pense c'est ce qu'on va faire
enfin c'est loin
c'est long
c'est terriblement long
a perdu mais c'est dur deux ans à faire
quatre heures de casse minimum sur cet
event l'a déjà aujourd'hui sa mise en
place cinq heures là dessus c'est c'est
vraiment long
prendre l'avion en fait tout le train un
peu comme quand tu es dans le tgv en
fait attend que ça passe
alors à l'ensam liszt
chimay pas envie qu enfin
faire un truc plus intéressant que les
olympiades terrible
mais quand même il se tient dans la
peine c'est terrible
bouclier en vrai j'aurais peut-être
faire un livre un live bukina
bouquinales agen
j'aurais peut-être dû prendre un bouquin
j'aurais fait un casse-croûte ag as.g
du bon petit jambon cru
mais
après ces magnifiques vous êtes quand
même 650 à suivre ça c'est quand même
énorme
ils ont tellement sur ay peu le truc sur
les autres langues ils sont quand même
moins
impressionnant
super merci ray mais bon là on est hyper
[ __ ] en vrai
honnêtement on enverrait un petit
comment s'appelle un petit baky kind un
petit humankind ambulance est plus
intéressant un
géant de rien c'est dans la plus tout le
monde va pas se taire pour le tt de mazo
tout à l'heure
dois dire que là on a peut-être du
ballon peut-être que lundi turbo gagner
dans 38 c'est fini
pas plus maintenant j'en ai joué des
milliers mais arrêter
j'ai cuite
ça repart à pile à l'heure ça c'est
nickel allez un futur bobines des
indiens la
croyais à vie dit qu'ils jouent contre
ret europe c'est magnifique
du géra 6
un étudiant un peu relou dans le tchat
je n'ai pas très envie de te band f de
base mais la tête obligeait quoi
très envie mais tu as il faut il faut un
les indiens qui ont mis le double
allende ils ont changé de joueurs en
fait
restez pas un mec super et pour être le
prochain magnus a peut-être sur garde
les sites aller stream américain mais
pas pour les autres noms temps des
chiens qui filtrent usa
le chien fait une dinguerie viêt-nam
avait ramené un paquet et de russie que
j'aime bien le chien l'a défoncé en fait
terrible jeu j'entendais une dinguerie
et oui
sûr qu'on était tous les deux avec me
chasse à filer droit
dupuis a plu t20 non non mais bon
moi je suis très sérieux il y avait mis
chat
je faisais hyper gaffe en fait
du coup il ya plus de tête
il était super bon quoi le seul sachet
c'est moi qui le voit maintenant
ok bon allez allez les indiens là il
faut bunga-bunga en mêlée point en vélo
sprint auch aléas non il faut mettre les
punto ch
ils ont changé ils ont mis eux
je suis pas sûr que le prénom soit
autorisée sur twitter
c'est autorisé sur twitter ce prénom ou
pas moi je casse tête passa sur ma
chaîne
a bah oui mais bon il faut faire
attention
en tranquille ça passe ou pas
en rêve where prénom est quand même
spécial
leur est quand même spécial
je suis de retour
t'es pas rentable je sais pas comment il
s'est retrouvé avec ses prêts avec ce
prénom en fait
ça se prend elle est sympa j'ai déjà vu
à l espace sympa
je l avais pas la méchante
ouais je sais pas comment diviser la
porte et elle aurait pu changer de
prénom aussi un choix qu'elle est faite
elle et géorgienne de base l aller vivre
aux états unis alors et plus tu peux
changer de prénom quand tu changes de
pays
sa grand mère
mais ça peut être un prénom quoi mais
c'est dur à porter honnêtement
à apporter quoi
quand tu dis aux états unis ça est un
peu complexe
plus hanté avec un y à quoi elle savait
que comme c'est en quand tu changes
d'alphabet tu peux essayer de changer
une lettre qui se prononce pareil c'est
pas bête ouais
tu peux juste changer une lettre avec la
même prononciation c'est malin
c'est pas franchement c'est pas un
prénom facile à porter
on va voir ce que ça donne
apportez après c'est comme ça
bon ça ajoute partout après le truc
c'est que les indiennes les indiens et
les indiennes sont plus forts
globalement c'est comme ça que le match
avait bien tourner en leur faveur dans
le
dans le match aller
du coup les rues sont qualifiés pour la
finale rsa pour refaire russie inde
hier
santosh
800 tonnes d'orge puntos fait plaisir
selon santos santosh
où j'habite sans rature ratez pas grand
chose en même temps j'ai commis
alors on regarde un peu toutes les
parties en même temps on voit un peu ce
qui se passe pour le moment y a pas de
partie où ces gagnants on tourne il cote
un peu quoi
on attend qu'il se passe quelque chose
quoi
s'ajoutent partout il n'y a rien de
clair clair un nul part pour le moment
jean ping va se passer un truc peut-être
une déco
allez on va
et pas maintenant que ça va jouer de
façon sage ou dans les dernières minutes
ces trucs-là faut attendre encore un
petit quart d'heure pour que ça se
décante
c'est bien tu fais b4y av3k et c5
du fixe ça va pour gagner peut-être chez
les filles côté indien
parce que je pense weichs ali et arica
elles ont l'air bien
ça ça va
ouais
ça a l'air plus ou moins d'aller pour
les indiens
sur les échiquiers mix que c'est plus
difficile
bon
ça va très très vite se décanter
s'ils allaient punto ch qui sont mia
c'est complexe
ajoute partout
segal
ça je sais pas pour moi ç'a l'air cool
pour les blancs mais à quel point 5
c'est en fait c'est chaud
alors je me sens que les blancs sont
bien mais c'est fort
j'ai l'impression que ça tourne mal pour
les états unis en fait surtout qu'il
faut qu'ils gagnent en mini match 6 à
3,3 y perdent
la répression l'équipe de france
l'équipe de france ça n'existe plus il
tient elle a été éliminée
l'équipe de france elle a été éliminée
il faut trois points pour les indiens
il faut que trois points
non des pas bien et annie qui peuvent se
sauver
dur
attend que ça se décante on attend que
ça se décante
en page 2 pattes de poule
complet
rex comme position
intéressante mais bon
on verra comment ça se déroule un
ouais bah non il est pas bien
dit ça c'est égal
crush ça peut se retourner contre elle
en fait c'est peut-être chez les figues
ou gagner les l'inde
sur les stèles et chic et non mixtes en
fait c'est là qu'ils sont mieux sur les
trois échiquier non mixtes ils sont
mieux
on va voir un faut attendre un autre à
faire que d'attendre qu'ils jouent les
coûts
faut que ça clique
elle finit par clic et b4 mais bon
maintenant il peut y avoir des a4 pour
empêcher qui a et b 3
un clic sa clique
on s'affaire le zoom pour récupérer maso
en préparation du title tuesday
title allez
on va peut-être un peu nous égayer pour
cette fin de tournoi
m
je ménage encore une petite pub là
pour avoir les 6000 depuis par important
c'est important
petit tube qui part
rudy pour taina doit ici exactement donc
j'en vois un petit peu quoi peut-être
qu'ils avaient trois cas y c5
je n'oublie pas
avant qu'il se passe quelque chose dans
le deuil note que des petites des
petites pub qui partent
ça joue
elle a fait le à cuatro
et maintenant arica elle va partir pour
touré fin
car élèves 3 et machin est attaqué le
roi
on est presque au bout les gars avec un
peu de bol ça clique bien
tu as dû cavaler f3 maintenant elle est
faux que les indiens réussissent à fait
à faire le score la
sas ou frotte un peu
sa souffrance chez les premiers
échiquiers en fait
sassou frotte un petit peu côté indien
les fonds envoyés là gk3 la tour à tour
g5 à l'ephe o'callaghan hyaric à sa
fausse face victoire arica connue ou
faut qu'elle tienne qu'elle fasse draw
victor weiss schalit quand même
et après tenir une nulle sur les trois
dernier
vichy qui est foutue
vichy célestins en sueur
dame b 5 s'est terminée en fait ouais
vichy qui donne le point aux américains
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe les indiens qui sut
ils sont en train de leur échapper à
lempdes là on va être les pour une poche
ça vous pas les coûts là côté indien
ça joue pas les coûts allaient très fin
qui aurait 10 h 2
il ya ya ya ya ya ya ya ça tourne mal
ça tourne mal là pour nos amis indiens
les positions tourne mal en fait
que de la merde partout la sasa turbo de
choc partout
souffrant 14.4 pourtour f4f si ça ricane
devrait la gagner c'est vaishali moi qui
me fait peur
à ça tombe bien il n'y a pas eu dans ma
frange les trois intermédiaires à
l'éveil schalit qui fait le point
title commence à 8 on le sait un
sochalien mais qu'est ce que je fasse en
fait joué a commenté ce truc je suis
obligé
j'ai pas le choix j'ai pas deux fois
acquis ce qu'ils fassent
des riffs ah ben c'est pas de gaîté de
coeur j'aime bien cette expression c'est
pas de gaîté de coeur
est ce que ma zoé inscrit déjà la masse
masoe inscrits
d'amazon qui arrive
on va lui demander comment il se sent
salut mon maillot tu m'entends ou pas
tu m'entends
a tant fait sa ba salah faut que le
monde est un peu le volume mais c'est
bon je vais bientôt entendre
ouais ouais juste que je règle un peu le
volume mais ça va
ça va la forme
on va pas pouvoir suivre ton début parce
que je suis en train de finir les
olympiades en ligne la seule chose
magnifique c'est quoi ces demi finales
ah ouais c'est extraordinaire c'est sûr
que là c'est le bitstream non cette
chaise comme cette chasse comme on
attend la fin de sa est on est on est on
arrive on arrive tout de suite sur toi
quoi de ces j'ai vu que les américains
aient gagné non c'est les placer en
amérique mais états unis en demi
finale demi finale
une finale
attend j'étais complètement perdu
et sur talbot micro je pense que tu la
bombe jeudi la
voix annonce à la rebatte lui
j'étais sûr qu'il ait pris sur le
mépris et
la fota et voir sur zoom c'est bien lui
qui est sélectionné dans les micros
temps en temps on t'entend qui atteint
[Musique]
dans ma zone et pas chez le voisin maso
à masoe la maison manger c'est bon j'ai
ouï qui n'a bien à la chemise en
cellophane est là elle a représenté il
ya vingt-six que ces partis dans le
chatt 1 dès qu'il ya des dés qu'il ya
des débats aussi pourquoi ça écrit
cellophane draps
c'est très beau ça
microphone à ckoi microphone hd webcam
non il faut que tu es là
s'appelle snowball tu là ou pas
mais c'est pas grave c'est que c'est la
cam le micro t'inquiète pas on réglera
ça la prochaine fois on entend pas trop
mal ça va
attends là là là là tu es mieux tu l'as
dans le ton micro
la tasse natale qu'elle l'ag microphone
hd webcam ouais et l'autre est un autre
micro pas longtemps différemment des crs
deux microphones réalité paix définition
a tracé celui de l'ordi basse et le
mieux en fait celui de l'ordi d2 ont
rapproché là ça sera sûrement mieux non
mais ça va ça passe ça passe faudra
qu'on fasse un réglage le prochain coup
mais m mais c'est rien c'est rien
t'inquiète mais le punto chain
une [ __ ] concentre toi sur l'époux
une touche
depuis lors le match où on a perdu ta
came là par contre
c'est elle moi de sombres ouais c'était
inscrit là parce que ça commence dans
une minute
d'un problème hausse
ces montants inscrits je te vois non le
match à ces états unis inde du coup on
espère le deuxième point de l'inde
directement pour ensuite aller sur le tt
en fait tu vois il joue en quoi la
il joue en 15 + 10 mai ils ont commencé
il ya une demi-heure donc ça devrait
bientôt finir là
ok parfait
mais le truc c'est kitsch les indiens il
faut complètement de la merde place et
il était très très bien
lui dit
chuck
hayes schalit elle était gagnante c'est
n'importe quoi
alors sont les geishas licher pas
pourquoi ça me fait kiffer un maquis à
paris carine ouais mais ça va faire un
magasin doit il est en souffrance
c'est beau en fait les gens vont pas
fort en un mois j'aurais pas partie
aussi en
combiné moi je vais être sur un super
combiné genre toutes les parties en même
temps ce magnifique ben moi je vis ma
meilleure ville à
ma mère
c'est bon ça
prend du coup la jeune âge projet pareil
je suis tranquille là tu es tranquille
si tu veux tu peux même but d'ailleurs
non
si ça te dit que tu commandes pas trop
là bas non là je te prenais en fait
arica la gagner pour info
en vrai les gens dans le chat c'est en
mode quand est ce que ça se finit pour
avoir maso title tu vois
les 6e olympiades airlines tant pense
quoi je pense c'est complètement
inintéressant
verront intérêts par contre j'attends
ton capitanat avait en équipe de france
avec impatience sa part dès maintenant
c'est officiel on peut en parler ah bah
oui monsieur et capitaine de l'équipe de
france il va refaire une belle
de l'épopée je suis sur les tablettes ou
pas est-ce que tu peux officiel ici
chaque étape il ya des encore des
incertitudes pour la
composition
clairement mes performances ne t'ont pas
laisser de marque en contre
mais tu peux nous lâcher déjà des noms
de joueurs sélectionnés ou pas
bahia un peu de surprises en fait c'est
de l'équipe fort possible on y en a
juste une petite incertitude se rendre
mpl des passeurs de le prendre
velador end à levi pour ce à quoi
ce serait beau que tu le sélectionne pas
en mode full troll lui l'accord la être
fait sur deux jours sa peine avant j'ai
été déçu par ses performances en coupe
du monde
je ne prends pas
du coup
du coup je peux te dire je peux te dire
qu'on attend ça avec impatience et qu'on
suivra l'épopée 1 ça je peux te le dire
ayant vraiment votre coiffeur je crois
si tu réussis à ce que les tous les tous
les joueurs que tu as dans le viseur
accepte de jouer est un moyen d'avoir
une belle équipe
mais
de notre côté c'est chaud je suis pas
toi comment ça se passe mais nous ça
reste chaud les indiens
s'accroche mais ils ont un peu fermé la
porte
moi ça va l'objectif c'est quand même
essayer de commencer avec un sur un
parce que les derniers title il était
pas mal toujours partie avec une petite
épine dans le pied quand
donc on va essayer de bien faire un
petit coucou
aux stagiaires tech moi ce week-end ce
que je crois qu'ils regardent sauce
foire s'est bien passé ouais toujours
comme toujours
[Musique]
vraiment un plaisir d'entraîner ses
ces personnes-là très bon esprit tous
membres de la chaîne ouais sahara ils
n'étaient pas pas trop chiant non non
c'est pas genre
c'est que des crèmes du décret -
bonne nouvelle ça fait plaisir de savoir
que les gens ils sont à sympa en dehors
de pages
déjà parlé d'un bon ben moi ça fait
moins que les biographies on va être à
peu près de 150 personnes différentes et
150 crème il est toujours bon on attend
toujours le con mais on l'a pas atteint
quiète passe à venir se présenter à mon
avis
on l'attend on l'attend dans les bas
fonds
de la mer
or la très bonne tenue c'est que j'ai
l'impression que ça va partir en
we ça peut partir en trois saveurs en or
mais oui ça peut partir en taille break
mais dans ce cas là de toute façon je
pourrais venir un peu de voir ton title
pendant pendant la pause et je sais pas
comment se passe l'armageddon mais ça
doit être rapide
truc magnifique c'est que j'ai comme
écrit hier à thiès comme pour leur
demander décaler le title de mazo quoi
j'aurais du mazet joue le title c'est
très problématique sociale en ligne
ils n'ont pas compris la priorité en
fait
bon alors mon rôle est
dense et eris des indiens ils font
n'importe quoi
mais genre vraiment
impressionnante
impressions
il sortait une calèche de moi ouais mais
j'ai une poseuse s'emploie comme
al madar
belle diagonale
patrick le hyaric
accepté lieux loués bien sûr
ton taf et montgardon
je m'en viens chercher comment gagne 5
ans
c'était tout à fait mon garçon sait ce
que c'est con comme
c'est marrant
des risques un
petit risque
je peux te dire que ça égaliser en train
d'égaliser la cote américain
dès que ça égalise en fait je veux venir
je vais venir te voir s
ah ben ça va
score bien
sûr on sait bien aux oiseaux
elle partit en plus oui
j'étais une belle partie forêt un peu de
bol ya peut-être l'américain là qui
déconne un tout petit peu mais je crois
que ça suffit pas en fait
malheureusement
quoi le score l'a12 et demi un ennemi
mais le truc c'est qu'un indien il
déconne aussi en fait
donc on y va gagner la dernière c'est
quoi un temps à temps l'américain a
déconné la racaille premier set 6 et
prend la fuite oh non on ne sait pas
possible de ne pas voir ça non mais le
nul en dix ans il est nul non mon maso
prost charlatans quoi je vois pas que le
quart eli protègent non mais c'est grave
de pas voir ça non
et la foi aussi ses shows
voleur d'un indien coi
est la bâtisse et qui est la dernière
sevaille schalit mais de façon si père
lui c'est fini
tu me dire elle est complètement futur
ici de l'autre côté fin faut qu'ils
fassent un an et demi sur deux avec deux
positions de merde
il fonde sur deux s'appelle match nul
ils font un an et demi ça fait match nul
mais le problème c'est qu'ils sont mal
sur les 2 3 1 mais c'est en plusieurs
matches huawei hamas deux parties enfin
c'est n'importe quoi à dire qu'il ya
déjà eu un premier match entre ces deux
équipes ouais il ya une victoire
de l'inde un beau score ouais c'est pour
ça
parce que je vois kasteler budde
jusqu'au bout bah en fait les 26 va se
terminer avant la fin du title un
largement puisqu'après le tie break ça
va pas durer des plombes non plus hein
c'est parce que c'est le tie break mais
ça va être rapide
[Musique]
ouais ouais c'est vrai que badou moi
j'ai joué un peu avec l'équipe 2 à toi
tu as joué ce truc aussi joué avec
l'équipe de france très sympa le truc
lada partie
mamediarov
jassem hamid ya rohff et là ma caméra
frontale ne marche plus
donc j'ai une caméra elle devait avoir
deux caméras dont j'avais la caméra
téléphone de colter la frontale ne
marchait plus donc je demande si je peux
pas qu'un coup de téléphone ils me
disent non j'ai pas le droit à une bise
faut réparer je suis ben ouais t'es
gentil mais ce que je fasse moi oui bah
oui j'ai déjà riche pour enlever le bois
de son rôle de chambre devant google
chrome qui voudraient parfois donc le
mec il me parlait me parle bon
finalement une disent bon bah tu as
droit mais une deuxième coeur ait un
téléphone deuxième caméra je commence la
partie 4 minutes contre 15 minutes de
génial
voilà enfin du coup la fin tu vas tu
joues le truc mais vraiment tu t'en fous
donc la bombe
ça se ressent dans le jeu ça se ressent
sur le sujet
après tu vois un début on était un peu
motivés mais bon on pu les
contraintes relève et la biélorussie on
est complètement foutu je suis etienne
gagne sur des connexions un tu vois ces
âmes et doit être heureux de gagner sur
deco ouais bien sûr mais bon tu te dis
c'est quoi la coi à quoi ça rime
rien mais non rien on envoie ta gamescom
tu veux tu peux commenter ne pas
commenter non recevoir à m commenta
je commande que cette petite rose sont
les mots
entre un mec qu'un petit mexique honte
écrit c'est la plus belle des victoires
sur deco
ça c'est l'esprit qu'on aime
non mais bon après voilà c'est pour
l'intérêt sportif c'est pas ouf
moi ce que j'arrive pas à comprendre
c'est que lille ait refait une deuxième
fois en fait moi c'est ça qui me dépasse
complètement
dès vendredi toral approaching bon ce
sera quand même un peu plus marrant ou
alors du coup comme on dit c'est quoi on
est con bien joué segel format alors on
hénaff a joué ça c'est impressionnant
les neuf sages bruit ouais tu joues toi
ah bah vu ce que je t'ai écrit sur
what's app non ah oui ok pas moins
savent attendus mais mais du coup non je
fais que manager en fait sur à 18 heures
du coup je rentre chez moi à 18 heures
donc
je m'assurer que tout le monde soit
connecté tout mais en fait c'est une
arena 2 art hockey et du coup tu
ce que tu commentes en fait primer et du
coup elle
mais on a une belle équipe c'est qu'il
est neuf alors attends je vais te le
dire ça se peut qu'on un remplacement de
dernière minute mais les neuf cmv el
baki max lagarde romain edouard malbois
liés elliott je ne prononcerai pas son
nom mais c'est le papa mais en 10
j'espère pas me tromper ouais marquant
robert s
j'en oublie ou pas
wen mois elle voyait j'ai dit j'ai
peut-être pas l'image brouillée ils
étaient dix mille billets qu'attend mvl
baky robert s max lagarde romain edouard
cette base et
elliot marque ans et maëlle
neige
et donc c'est quoi c'est le résultat des
quatre médias les résultats des sept
meilleurs au hockey
et après si on se qualifie on perd bas
qui pour sûr on perd quelques jeunes ya
peut-être moi qui rentrent en joker on
verra comment ça se passe si on se
qualifie
pas de corps en étau et non il peut pas
il joue la coupe d'europe des clubs en
fait de base l'équipe
si ça a été comme je voulais il y aurait
eu un peu moins de jeunes à la place sur
une grille tchouk cornetto ok mais les
deux joué la coupe d'europe de clubs et
du coup j'ai un peu abandonné ouais et
les bills et en libye le respect et
libye
[Musique]
et
en italie
josiane italienne
à
part thierry
blin
[Musique]
qu'on démarre les
[Rires]
départageront look l'état mystique où on
va bah oui stérile ce jeu quoi tu en
voilà
j'en peux plus de ces miss clique de
merde qu un stratosphérique
en émoi le vrai jeu quoi
en laissant des écoles pourra schisme
bon magnifique la salle a été là
celle-là l'été shenzhen chercheurs à
temps c'est une blague il ya quinze
minutes de pause entre saïd tie break
on va t'il être ravie comme
une blague
quinze minutes de pause un essai une
blague
encore 15 minutes 1 c'est à dire qu'il
ya déjà eus il va ailleurs 25 minutes de
pause entre la
bon bah
on va serrer la main
à tour agissent
comme s'ils avaient tellement affiche en
face
et thébaux turaci
bien bon
quel dommage ce tour à 6
j'allais un peu ce que fait carreau
[Musique]
après la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on a
vraiment le temps de voir encore ta
prochaine partie
mais quand j'ai vu 13 me de pub de pause
qui restait encore treize minutes de
pause j'ai halluciné en fait
c'est passé comme si au foot en fait à
la fin pour tirer les buts les tirs au
but a et 25 de pause quoi
c'est
extraordinaire en fait
donc ok donc c'est donc c'est les sept
meilleurs et du coup lancé quoi on joue
comme pour mon équipe on joue contre
trois autres équipes on est quatre un
jeu que compte trois autres équipes le
premier se qualifie
et les deuxièmes et les troisièmes jouer
un tie break 6 enfin pour savoir qui
passe au et c'est quoi les autres
équipes ou alors ça je peux aller
regarder si tu veux
je sais plus sur calmein c'est en fait
j'ai pas leurs compositions et il sait
des pays mais en vrai a le truc c'est
que tu peux faire jouer des joueurs de
n'importe quel pays donc c'est pas parce
que
on va je vais dire le pays qu'on va
vraiment savoir qui joue quoi
c'est vraiment organiser de manière très
complexe honnêtement
en fait ils ont fait beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de mails où il ya des
changements de règles ya des trucs et tu
retrouves plus rien à force
j'imagine ok on joue avec l'argentine
l'inde
ne s'est pas forcément la bonne nouvelle
est la pologne
la pologne je pense à pologne argentine
je pense ça peut passer un way ans -
chiens de 1 re à lallaing ça dépend ça
dépend de la connexion en fait l'inde
ouais
pressez pas des ennemis
mais peut avoir une équipe à la con avec
avec que d'efforts avec vie dit le
double à nand
machin nihal sarine tu vois ouais ouais
mais
bon on est enfin
et les prix sont cammas est intéressant
c'est quoi en fait c'est on passe ce ms
pasqua commet dans les deux
après on rejoue le 21 juin croit et
c'est de nouveau quatre équipes
et c'est de nouveau le même système et
après il n'en reste plus que quatre la
dernière fois et c'est la grande finale
genre
mais en vrai les prix sont pas ridicules
comment ils luttent contre la triche a
les deux caméras à ses deux caméras
andré américaine de gériatrie en fait
moi il faut que je lise les trucs on
voit peut-être
hockey deux caméras ok
mais les prix choix même si on termine
dernier à 75 euros par joueur de prix
même si on perd tout même s'ils ont fini
quatrièmes en fait
s'ils ont fini deuxièmes
qualifiés quoi pense que les filles je
crois que si on va jusqu'au bout c'est
dans les flashs et plus c'est dans les
2000 euros par joueur si on gagne le
truc où 3000
regarde le truc total mais ça s'accumule
avec avec ce que tu gagnes à chaque à
chaque tour en fait on peut pas dire
exactement
où envoyer le beau jeu
moi je suis parti du principe que
c'était que du bonus et que s'ils ont
fini si on perd c'est 75 après je sais
pas je crois que si on gagne c'est
peut-être 250 le premier tour par joueur
et si hockey et peut-être après le
deuxième tour et 2003 les équipes jeunes
joueurs ouais ok
après très important parce que si on
passe le 1er tour je fais probablement
ma rentrée pour le tour suivant donc là
ça va être bénéfique
ils n'ont plus aucune chance bah oui
normalement je remplace baky ou mvl pour
le tour d'après donc tu vois je ne fait
que renforcer
et donc la arena il ya des règles encore
bas ou des trucs à faire non c'est la
main après ce sera la même chose que
l'aréna qu'on a déjà fait quoi ouais
mais tu es toujours dit que quand tu
sais quand tu as une voix exposition aux
faut abandonner à la balle à faut
regarder un peu au cas par cas suivants
contre qui tu voues machin parce que là
tu donnes des points aux adversaires
aussi voilà est donc assez loin
dans la salle sont moins intéressants -
si tu joues contre une équipe
donc si tu vois je vois qu'au bout d'une
heure et demie une équipe qui est largué
son genre l'argentier d un argentin est
peut-être parti de merde non mais là tu
peux y livrer de guillemots tu peux
faire nul rapidement pour rebondir ouais
et donc c'est le point qui suivra car
ankara des petits messages ou je sais
pas si j'aurai le droit faut que je
demande je suivrai ça c'est sûr
du coup on n'a pas le droit de t'ecouter
évidemment ça c'est sûr mais je verrai
si je peux faire des petits des petits
sms des petits trucs qu'après on peut
aussi assurer sur des chaises qu'on peut
suivre
les classements sur le côté comme étant
un classement sur le côté et
travailler encore 6 minutes 30 de pause
quoi je mets toi ça rejoue pas
aller encore roberto qui vous amène à
trois cavaliers sama trois cavaliers ou
pas
ça
mais en fait ils troll ça fait il a il a
deux cents coups en fait il a fait à des
cavaliers des tours et il joue pendant
des plombes il est vraiment débile lui
payer c'est roberto
c'est un gars qui m'a déjà insulté après
il m'a bloquée parce que je le bats à
chaque fois
et des stream en portugais
allait bien relou quoi
[Musique]
d'abord il m'a déjà insultés en tout cas
il fait exprès du coup là mais avant il
avait une tour en plus ces machines fait
exprès fait perdre son temps à tout le
monde c'est pour ça que ça dure
c'est pas il fait durer pour faire le
malin ou pas j'en sais rien moi on pas
il a fait nul
mais très con en face
aux litiges
il est exceptionnel
quel champion
il avait une pourquoi il a fait trop
avec ce troisième quart et les
l'aurifère dames c'est vraiment un coup
ça fait du bien de voir des
graphismes à laquelle godard
jacques choisissent contre qui tu joues
alexandre bouger bref tu connais j'ai
quand c'est ça que je voulais faire
bon joueur
c'est beaucoup sur le jazz comme
internationale pour voir comment ça
reprend mais ils m'ont mis deux minutes
trente de pub
a été plus beaux
gains encore marqué à 16
une machine non
je n'arrive pas sarko ça reprend à cause
des pubs
très drôle
j'étais en train de me dire quoi j'ai un
oui j'étais en train de me dire ah oui
mais encore 32 qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
au norwich associe c'est intéressant
à une belle position à sa
paire de
fourbes et 3
m les toros tente
donc là c'est c'est débile de départage
houssard écoute je sais pas c'est pour
ça que tu sur le live officiel mais en
fait ça pendant 2 minutes 30 y'a rien
écrit
[Musique]
à trop
gens qui écrivaient série que depuis que
depuis que tu arrivais l'audience
augmente un petit à petit sur czech
comme depuis qu'on suit plus les
olympiques
fait on a trouvé le secret pour les
olympiades appelé maso
montrer nos demis clic jeu touristique
était beau quand même à y arriver nulle
part on n'attendait pas tranquille on
discutait pas
il a fait plaisir aussi je te cache pas
mais merde
t'as vu qu'une partie soit des
olympiades en ligne dans trois ans j'ai
joué je veux contre l'egypte
et contre
un sur les niches pour
tafer cale à cale score du coup j'ai
fait zéro une mission entrant
oui c'est pas ben en fait ça me déprime
tellement secret que
je jouais un niveau et catastrophe
n'étaient pas censés jouer finalement
j'ai joué je sais plus pour quelle
raison
je pense la prod classique sera plus
drôle nombre de projets tic je vais
t'offrir
globalement c'est que deux heures machin
non mais là ça me bouthillier le suisse
un truc que voilà non mais c'est pas
long je veux dire par là c'est pas long
feu et c'est pas long
je pense qu'il a des rares points de
connexion je peux pas
tout cas ça fait le point
alors attends ça donc ils vont rejouer à
sains en fait ils changent la cadence et
heroes ou quoi
par contre je sais pas si ce qui se
passe si refondu de quoi il vaut mieux
pas qu'il refasse tulle en fait
trois sinon c'est l'enfer
à temps pourquoi ça reprend pas
c'est pourquoi ça reprend pas voilà ça
fait quand même 25 minutes de pause quoi
déjà
calme je sais pas un écho quand c'est
possible mais outre les échecs on
réussisse pas à faire quelque chose de
normal en fait ça me désespère à force
ça me désespère
un truc normal pourquoi je sais pas a
comme tous les sports en fait ouais ben
bella enfin ils fondent ils peuvent
faire des choses bien il faut juste
arrêter les trucs online sites ou pas
non mais je sais mais tu as même la
mettons tu fais online quoi pourquoi pas
je sais pas mais pourquoi 25 me de pause
avant le tie break ah oui oui ok ah bah
non macias et
je veux dire par là tu vois les tournois
la scène que phil cas pourquoi après
après pour avoir été un peu dans le truc
j'ai vu que c'était leur bête il est en
sueur il se pourrait des trucs mais
en fait les lois qui respectent rien et
qui enfin ils laissent leurs écrans à
lui et son plein le choix du tout ça au
bordel pour la [ __ ] il n'a pas le droit
de lancer les matches
ça décale tout est donc ça peut poser
des problèmes sur un thème chose
en arbitres vs10 guy qui a
d'ailleurs j'ai pensé il ya j'ai pensé à
notre comme le truc combien de guy
contre les rues de dax
ce que hier je suis allé voir le match
des légendes à bordeaux ouais c'était 15
légende française de rugby qu'on 15
légende française de football une
mi-temps foot imitant le hockey est
sympa et chabal il y avait une dame à
qui avait castagnet
yachvili la grosse équipe
et gros les grands écrans rugbyman et au
football dont il y avait des bons
joueurs papa des changes
et donc quand je voyais chabal lancée là
certes un peu rigoler
j'imagine et combien de grippe est
arrêté chaque année mais les
footballeurs il arrive un peu à les
arrêter ou quand en fait normaux au
foot les footballeurs métro parce qu'en
fait les rugbymans savent jouer au foot
quoi ouais ouais sa balle qui touche oui
mais alors aussi une chose intéressante
c'est que
le rugbyman qui est beaucoup plus que le
footballeur a tjrs n'aurais pas pensé
bon c'est à dire que physiquement bon eh
bien ils ont un peu de poids mais pas
tous déjà y en a beaucoup qui sont très
affûtés encore le genre yachvili casse à
lienz et les mêmes n'ont pas bougé bon
ok ils ont pris peut-être garder un peu
de muscle mais enfin silhouette ils sont
là quoi rire est plein après califano
ont ils n'avaient pas bougé pas boucher
a peu bougé chabal - cheval est un pas
trop bouger par contre les footballeurs
ou lula la paresse à saint marc et moi
rien laisser aller ouais c'est notable
c'était en tout cas elle est football en
v3 et au rugby donc c'est pas du rugby
pura n'y a aucune chance pour le
footballeur c'est du temps c'est à dire
c'est rugby mais t'as pas le droit aux
plaquages et et que tu touches trois
fois l'adversaire cas le ballon ça passe
de l'autre côté ouais parce que c est
donc bon ben là il est enfin au niveau
du jeu demain il n'y a aucune chance
pour les wii les footballeurs ils ont
ils omis aucun respect ça va trop vite
de l'autre côté wen lauret les autres
ils passent très bien la balle
et youku on voit là une gare nage alors
c'est en 3 + 2 1 ça a repris de l'autre
côté
ça joue
dur à dire ainsi c'est chic et en même
temps c'est dur à suivre en 3 + 2 pour
se faire une idée de ce qui se passe
dans le mât est en fait
donc écoute chez pas trop pour le moment
je te dirai quand une des deux équipes
rend vraiment le dessus pour le moment
c'est dur à dire
complexe
mais roberto c'est extraordinaire comme
ce qu'il a fait avec ses trois cavaliers
la partie d'avant génial
on dit phil rogers rapporte gagnant ça
fait plaisir ça
oui ça fait plaisir
et chirurgien il est clairement très
fort mais juste en finale il faut que tu
l'entraîneur maso ouais on a vu ça hier
les pions sur la mauvaise couleur
goudjo firoud déjà mieux mais bon
belmont gagnant c'est un grand mot
or
les rapports moi il m'arrive
impressionne l'a dernièrement je sais
pas si c'est un feu de paille et que ça
c'est un drap ou si la step up mais il
va il va taquiner le top 5 à force 1-1
il a posé un peu son jeu là
roberto est heureux en train de faire
partie des 50 ans
pas pourquoi ça joue pas
mais roberto c'est beau ce qu'il a fait
quand même
10 - quand ça commence par curiosité
je joue qu'
el professor
of hand
avec un zèle du pet laquelle la maison
du papier
[Musique]
donc là en fait faux papiers 3 3 c'est
ce qu'on vise à ça on vise pas le 3-3
ray pas tout compris
j'ai l'impression que les indiens sont
devant un peu partout chez les filles et
chez les garçons c'est chaud
chez les fils et toutes les indiennes
qui sont mieux
chez les garçons ça a l'air de bien se
passer aussi en fait donc un gars qui
est
où c'est vraiment chaud
et non chez les garçons ils sont
défoncés en fait tâche et les mixtes
pour être précis
prendre son mal autant les américains ne
partent ou
sont mal autant partout un an il ya des
bugs de temps
c'est vraiment catastrophique
et le bonheur
je renvoie en fait s'il joue sur chasse
comme pour huer des bugs de temps sur de
chasse comme
complexe
la question
[Musique]
pas très intéressant
ouais dans les filles à l'efficience pas
super bien pour les années
où la non il ya une [ __ ] de gaffe
c'est incroyable lavez l'indian junior
qui était gagnante elle est complètement
foutue maintenant
elle a filé une pièce en un
elle est passée de - 5 50 à +3 pour
l'autre on a un coût
[Musique]
on aime ça même ceux je bouge
ce que je joue sa
[Musique]
requête
par quatre
je crois que les américains ils sont
gagnantes partout
à claire y aller en grandeur
complètement débile il a filé un pion en
un
c'est incroyable
oh là là
alors athema temps 3 et elle est passée
de maths entre [ __ ] c'est terrible il
ya maintenant deux ans il a vu rôle
indienne qui reprend qui reprend le
dessus l'américaine à la page du mathan
2 c'est pas possible
incroyable non sa gaffe de partout en
fait c'est complexe je pense à faire
match nul sans rigoler c'est complexe
ah mais attends nancy c'est juste yal
indienne qui est tombé avant de faire ma
tondeuse
si le corps est juste c'est les indiens
qu'ils vont gagner sur soi des
connexions web peut-être dès qu en fait
ce qu'ils avaient m'attendais à l'appa
cliquez
[Musique]
l'esprit saint
donc je sais pas ça dépend soit ces bugs
du score et l'autre abandonner ce qui m
attend d'eux soit cédée connexion
parce que sinon les américains ça fait
un deux
trois et demi et c'est gagné vrai je
sais pas honnêtement je ne sais pas ça a
pu gagner sur deco en fait
ce
qui est magnifique c'est le cas
ah c'est beau parce que l'année dernière
c'est déjà joué sur une déconnexion
c'est beau aussi cette année ça se joue
là dessus quoi
des connexions enfin je joue un plein de
voix la
honte à toi
à toi sens et les américains c'est les
américains qui mûrit dans tous les cas
puisqu'il ya eu un choc du coût de la
joueuse indienne mais je pense que ça
l'a complètement à
ça a complètement détruit
l'antique que ça marche debout je salue
c'est gagné pour les américains maso on
va voir faire le switch et on va pouvoir
aller le voir donc bravo
bravo américain
on se retrouve dans une petite seconde
avec matt aut eric l'échiquier